what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so like Green Lanterns is the best thing
coming out of BC rebirth right now hi
this is such a great story because this
is lost in time right but like I would
call it the return of volthoom because
it's basically him coming back and like
the form that people are so familiar
with now in terms of all the voloom
stuff we'll get through that as we get
into this video but one thing to keep in
mind is that on the whole Jessica Cruz
and Simon Baz had never actually been
trained as Green Lantern's that's one of
the reasons why the Green Lantern story
is so cool is because if you'd never
read any of the classic stuff if you
never read like blackest night brightest
day Sinestro Corps war any of that kind
of stuff you basically learn about the
Green Lantern's as they learn about them
now what we covered up to this point to
get you caught up is that for the most
part Jessica Cruz's history with
volthoom was initially ambiguous all we
knew was that the crime syndicate of
America basically an evil version of the
Justice League from Earth three had
invaded during the new 52 in a story
called forever evil and the idea was
that the crime said the kid had their
own Green Lantern he went by the name
power ring but he basically possessed a
Lantern ring that was inhabited by the
spirit of a being named wolf hoon now
this ran and really kind of seemed to go
side by side with an existing character
named volthoom who was basically the
first person to ever wield a Lantern
ring the problem with this was that
there was no reconciliation we didn't
really know if there was a relationship
between those two characters now as we
found out in my videos the first will
and testament of voloom of the first
Lantern
that the power ring as it existed and
was possessed by the voloom entity was
basically another aspect of the first
Lantern voloom himself he had traveled
in his effort to try to save his own
universe he had come across different
realities somebody took in a piece of
his essence threw it into a ring on
earth 3 which was passed down the line
until eventually it reached that
realities version of Hal Jordan who
invaded earth during for every bolt and
then once he was defeated the ring sawed
out Jessica Cruz so that was the whole
idea with regards to her characters
progression now for the most part and
Jessica Cruz is always dealt with like a
lack of confidence the belief that she
wasn't ever really a Green Lantern
that took her forever to be able to
wield like Green Lantern constructs she
wasn't really able to consistently be
useful to Simon bass as the two Green
Lantern's on earth now as time
progressed that began to change as she
grew more confident in herself as she
basically began moving away from feared
meeting her life - tapping into her
willpower she was able to create these
constructs but again despite the things
these two characters have done facing
against the Red Lanterns facing off
against the Phantom ring we'll talk more
about that as we get into this video at
the end of the day they were never
really trained as Green Lantern's and so
what ended up happening at the info a
story is they were basically whisked
away for training essentially told you
have to come to mow go in order to be
trained on how to use your rings the
problem with this is that force on
advanced to a degree and really more so
for Jessica Cruz she's never really left
earth and that's kind of the big caveat
to this when she was the Green Lantern
she was fighting alongside the Justice
League she was doing all conjugal stuff
but he was always on earth it was always
in a familiar setting when she's out
there floating around in the darkness of
space
it's totally unfamiliar territory any
number of things could happen it would
result in her dying I mean it's really
just the ring on her finger that keeps
her alive and that recognition really
just kind of reins home in the idea that
she's so overwhelmed and so in the midst
of her in and Simon Baz really kind of
being teleported away to a mojo she
really does kind of shouts emergency
stop Simon bass keeps going but she's
just kind of left out in the middle of
space now of course her inexperience
with the ring is really highlighted here
but other than anything else because for
any Green Lantern if they knew where
their residence was supposed to be if
they knew where they were supposed to go
it would just say ring chart a course
for mojo and the ring would just take
him to Mogo and that would be the end of
that no muss no fuss but do you have no
idea what it means to be a Green Lantern
when you have no idea where it is that
you're going you're basically thrust in
this impossible situation but
fortunately for her Kyle Rayner comes
along now remember Kyle Rayner if you're
if you haven't been reading Hal Jordan
in the Green Lantern Corps Kyle Rayner
basically lost his connection to the
white lanterns that was a great big huge
thing about his character it was kind of
like this soft reboot for Kyle Rayner
the you know indication and all signs
point to the idea that dr. Manhattan was
the one that basically destroyed the
white Lantern Corps but regardless of
who it was it had initiated the whole
thing the result is that Kyle Rayner
went back to being a Green Lantern now
of course the reason why he's here is to
also help aid Jessica Cruz in
understanding what it means to be a
Green Lantern because really again
because she's been on earth she only
knows the role in so far as being a
superhero on earth but the Green
Lantern's duties are never to just their
home planet it's to the entire sector
and so there are instances where Green
Lantern's will just have to forego one
plan
in order to save another that's just
kind of the role they play it's just the
way the game gets done and so because of
that Karina really entered it introduces
her to this idea that as a Green Lantern
there's a massive amount of
responsibility but there's also a lot of
gratitude if you play the role the way
that you're supposed to in this instance
he brings her to a planet of people who
were attacked by some you know crazy
alien racers live along those lines but
Kyle Rayner had helped to basically
nurture this race help to you know
restore them back to greatness and it
returned they were grateful for it and
so this is just another aspect to keep
in mind where the Green Lantern that yes
the universe is massive which is why
they're given sectors but there's a lot
more to take care of out there than just
the planet Earth now of course this
coincides and her arriving back to Mogo
and again it's really Jessica Cruz
getting a full eye view in terms of all
these different lanterns that are out
there all the different races that exist
things like that because remember the
idea of encountering aliens is brand new
to her and so in the midst of all this
she's of course met with Kilowog you
know more or less the guy who used to be
the jewel instructor for the Green
Lantern Corps she's also introduced to
what we already know in Hal Jordan of
the Green Lantern Corps that the Green
Lantern's and the Sinestro Corps are
basically working together working in
unison since sinestro's no longer part
of the picture but ultimately they're
both brought before Kilowog and
everybody for the purpose of being
trained now the other half of this is
the character of Raimi and Rani was
newly introduced he's part of DC rebirth
but the idea was that Rama's served as a
way for writer Sam Humphreys to begin
the process of just kind of expanding on
or completely revamping these origins
stories these classic events that went
into the Green Lantern chronology but
were never fully fleshed out in the 10
years but Geoff Johns wrote the entire
Green Lantern run that people hail as
being one of the greatest comic runs
ever and so again it allows these little
small tidbits these little itty-bitty
goodies to be kind of thrown into the
story and it really just kind of beefs
up the entire Green Lantern landscape so
of course in this instance what we knew
is that the spirit of all Foom had
basically lived on where originally we
thought he had been killed during the
whole wrath of the first Lantern story
and all that kind of stuff his essence
continued to live on because he's
effectively immortal he's the living
embodiment of the emotional spectrum and
so as long as the emotional spectrum
exists he'll exist there's no real
surefire way to actually kill him the
issue with this is that during the
previous story arcs volthoom he
basically taken over the body of Remmy
but nobody knew what was going on now
with regards to everybody watching these
events unfold to their eyes Ramy is one
of the original guardians of the
universe as the idea is that since he
was the one that basically created the
original Green Lantern rings the idea is
to bring him back in and to see why some
of these rings are malfunctioning now of
course this is really kind of a
background plot to what's going on for
the first half of this story for the
first half it's really just training and
it's actually pretty cool because what
is up happening here is Kyle Rayner and
Guy Gardner are invoked and the reason
why is because of the fact that if you
go through and you look at the different
lanterns that exist out there Wow Guy
Gardner Hal Jordan Kyle Rayner Jon
Stewart the earth-based Green Lantern's
for the most part Jon Stewart Guy
Gardner and Kyle Rayner are basically
just different facets of how Jordan's
personality they represent the kind of
things that make him who he is in the
case of Jon Stewart he is tactical he's
meticulous at the same time Kyle Rayner
can be a little bit reckless and he can
also be the funny guy and when it comes
down to it Guy Gardner will do whatever
it takes to win and so because of those
things guy Gardner's really like the
powerhouse of the Green Lantern Corps
he's the fighter he's the guy that you
want in your corner whatever things go
too hot and so in this instance his
training with Jessica Cruz is intense
the basis behind this training is what
happens if you're in a situation where
you don't have your Lantern ring or what
you're facing somebody who's just as
capable of using their ring as you are
it's not just about being able to
conjure constructs it's about being able
to work in your surroundings and that's
the lesson that's being taught to
jessica Cruz at the same time with Simon
bass he's very you know look I can just
go in and I can punch and everything
will be okay but Kyle Rayner is not that
way kyle rayner success in the 1990s the
reason why his role as the Green Lantern
was so popular among fans is because
artists and writers began crafting Kyle
Rayner in a way where he would use these
far more complex and intricate
constructs he'd make these giant anime
you know mecha devices whatever it is of
people calling you to create these super
elaborate complex constructs because he
was an artist and so he would pour his
artists skills into his lantern
constructs and so what is are happening
here is he's basically making the point
- Simon bass it's not enough to just
come running in guns blazing sometimes
you have to be smart you have to
understand that there's no way for you
to simply overcome a
or a number of foes through sheer
strength alone sometimes you have to out
think them and so again it's creating
this idea that Green Lantern's have to
be broad they have to be very
well-rounded in terms of how they use
their skills because as Sinestro Corps
war taught a lot of the Green Lantern's
at any point in time they could find
themselves surrounded by a litany of
foes that they can't all defeat at the
same time so they have to be fast on
their feet they have to be fast in terms
of how they react they have to be able
to counter every step of the way while
keeping themselves alive and protecting
those around them now again
transitioning into the second part of
this story this focuses a lot on the
travel Lantern now again the travel
Lantern is something that we've fleshed
out over the course of our discussions
on Green Lantern rebirth but for all the
folks who were new here the chronology
of volthoom basically went like this
originally when he was created by geoff
johns he was just there one day and he
was just the guy who taught the origins
of the universe how to tap into the
emotional spectrum the idea is that with
full thoom he basically had his original
ring the problem is that his original
ray allowed him to mainline the entirety
of the emotional spectrum and with
absolute power comes absolute corruption
well really is absolute power corrupts
absolutely but the idea here was that
volthoom just kind of went mad with
power that was the original story now
that original story has remained intact
to a degree the difference is that a
backup story was attitude we've
basically told us that both oome hailed
from a different universe and volthoom
sought to basically keep his universe
alive by jumping to different realities
and finding those with the power to
travel back to his home universe and
save it the problem with this is that
when volthoom traveled to these
different universes again he ended up on
earth 3 some magician basically took a
piece of his essence threw it in the
power ring but everywhere he went he
ended up finding people who just didn't
have the power to help him achieve his
goal until he showed up in the main DC
Universe and encountered the guardians
of the universe the result is that they
allowed him to begin teaching them to
tap into the emotional spectrum the
result was that they started going
through all these different things
trying to figure out which part of the
emotional spectrum was the most balanced
ultimately settling on will in the form
of the Green Lantern Corps which
eventually led to voloom basically being
the first Lantern and so on and so forth
in the first history kind of continues
as it did when he was originally
introduced by Jeff John so because of
all that
the idea here is that with voloom
operating inside the body of remy is
basically this goal where he has been
brought in by the guardians of the
universe to figure out why some of these
rings are malfunctioning but his goal is
to find out what happened to the travel
Lantern with him basically taking over
the body of Ramy and trying to figure
out what's going on or at least what
happened to the travel Lantern in the
end his only goal is to go home that's
it it's not super complicated now of
course going through and trying to find
the travel answer he ultimately ends up
figuring out that while the travel
Lantern has kind of been you know
repurposed to basically form this seven
original Green Lantern rings that he
simply can't locate where these original
Green Lantern rings you're at there's
really no information there except for
one and the person who has one of those
original Green Lantern rings is Jessica
Cruz now this is one of those cool
moments where we talk about how
something small happens at some point
and then it turns out to be significant
that's the way the Green Lantern's
always been done there's always been a
writer coming along and saying hey
here's the thing here and then that's it
you never hear hide nor hair of it until
you get around to like six months later
and then suddenly it's a huge point of
the story and in this instance when
Jessica Cruz originally received the
earth 3 power ring both they were just
talk to her constantly taunt her keep
her in a state of fear keep her under
control that kind of a thing when
Darkseid war happened at the end of new
52 and it led into DC rebirth when she
became a Green Lantern she got an actual
Green Lantern ring and to those of us
who were readers we were just like okay
cool a Green Lantern ring no muss no
fuss what this story tells us is she got
one of the one of the Lantern rings that
belonged to one of the original seven
lanterns the reason why that matters is
because a her ring is the key that can
be used to access the travel Lantern and
allowable phoom to go home and so that's
why this stuff is so cool now of course
with Jessica cruising summon bath is
basically finishing their training what
is up happening is they're basically
brought to a place called the vault of
Shadows now this is cool because this is
one of those instances where we
basically learned that again the
guardians of the universe have all kinds
of secrets while the guardians of the
universe consider themselves protectors
of the universe while they were the
creators of the Green Lantern Corps
essentially a humanitarian peacekeeping
force with a power to kill those who
were extremely dangerous the guardians
of the universe operate under the mantra
of the Green Lantern's and the universe
will learn what they need to know if and
when they
- no it ultimately what ends up
happening here is that in this moment
Jessica Cruz ensign and bass are brought
to this vault basically this vault of
shadows and the goal is to basically use
the ring of Jessica Cruz to access the
travel Lantern and then just return back
to his own universe in the midst of all
this they're basically met with the
arrival of her Anna now the cool thing
about his character is he's appeared
before actually he appeared in Green
Lantern's rebirth issue number 18 which
was again some of the stories that we
saw earlier but it's the idea that he
knows who Jessica Cruz and Simon bass
are the crazy thing about this is that
remember as one of the original lanterns
and as a person with his own set of
abilities he can see through
hallucinations he can see through things
as they really are as opposed to how
people would like them to be the reason
why this is important is because he
immediately picks up on the fact that
this is not Ramy that this is Ramy
possessed by the spirit of wealth ooh
and so immediately he tries to go out
and attack now remember Simon Baz and
Jessica Cruz don't know about this they
have no idea and it's very easy for
volthoom to kind of pawn this off and
say well the guy's been living in
isolation forever he's just a crazy dude
we'll just keep him here in stasis and
then we'll go out and we'll investigate
and we'll try to see if we can do what
it was we were here to achieve what he
was here did find was the first Lantern
ring now one of the things that I want
you guys to notice is how this Lantern
ring operates how it conducts itself the
first Lantern ring is part and parcel to
volthoom himself it's basically a ring
tagged directly to him and so because of
this there's a huge difference between
the first Lantern ring and the phantom
ring in truth in a lot of ways they are
very very similar the phantom ring was
created by Ramy as this ring that
anybody could pick up it didn't require
you to be able to overcome great fear
and instill fear in others instead you
could just walk into any work pick it up
and use it and you were able to
basically channel the different
abilities of the emotional spectrum the
difference here is that as far as I'm
aware the phantom ring did not allow a
person to use all the powers of the
emotional spectrum at the same time the
ring of Illume does the actual first
Lantern ring literally just mainlined
the entirety of the emotional spectrum
in to fall through and this is kind of a
cool moment because we would expect him
to basically lose his mind and just go
back to being a bad guy again but not
necessarily an argument could be made
here that when he was first endowed with
all this
it was more than he could handle it's
giving a 16 year old a key to a
Lamborghini of course they're gonna
crash it but if you give that key to a
45 year old man he'll be wiser he'll be
more experienced he'll be able to handle
that kind of a car much much better I
wish I had that kind of a car but the
idea is the head is that with full tube
he's grown wiser over the years he knows
what his goal is he's able to control
this power and so the result is that
with Simon Baz and Jessica Cruz being
fully fledged lanterns they are no
consequence to Voltaire not in the
slightest
and so in this instance his goal is to
simply snatch the ring of Jessica Cruz
and of course Simon Baz is incapacitated
in this instance and Jessica Cruz is
able to overcome her fear and try to
face off against full foon
but at the end of the day it doesn't
matter because where he keeps saying
should have a lantern and take off the
travel Lantern recognizes the voice of
both une whisking away but not with full
Foom instead it whisks away with Simon
Baz and Jessica Cruz and so these two
characters while volthoom is still left
in the main DC Universe these two
characters are simply shot out into the
multiverse knocked out to earth 15 sent
over to the to the reality that both
doom hails from this is gonna be kind of
a cool moment because the indication
here is that we'll actually see what his
universe looks like now is a pretty cool
scenario it's a pretty cool situation
but anyway guys again one of my favorite
stories coming out of DC right now when
it comes to the Green Lantern's but if
you guys are new here to come as
explained and make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you guys later peace
[Music]